[Applaus]
[Musik]
und narben der partner ich störe doch
hoffentlich nie warum sollten sich hören
dass wir diesmal begrüßen keine
blaskapelle engagiert habe
der partnerverein eingelegt wir erwarten
doch nicht etwa ein in seinem darm im
besucherpark und gottes wurde schneider
ich erwarte doch keinen damenbesuch aus
und so kommt jetzt nur heidi das
schielende opossum grund vorbei was also
ich habe gestern spontan im internet
eine ticket reise gebucht und zwar nach
island ins reich der geysire und ich
wollte sich fragen ob sie ganz spontan
als meinen allerwertesten auf den keks
wieder nahe gewesen könnten
spontan und schauen
man hofft ja ich komme gleich ja schatz
ich komme gleich in die ewigkeit
ich schaff genannt hast ewigkeit her
dass wir überhaupt miteinander geht um
die auch immer schaut ich habe ja alter
jugend fotos von mir ich weiß auch nicht
wie die meine sachen gerutscht sind du
hast du auch noch sachen von den
fehlenden staub sondern die möchte ich
zurück amt bei der hertha hat ihr damals
gesagt dass ein roboter staubsauger ein
roter staub sagen echt nicht sein ding
nicht nach aber in rosa stopp andere
frage
wieso wir haben doch gesagt dass wenn es
vor dem scheidungstermin noch mal
zusammensetzen
ja sicher aber doch nicht heute hier
waren denn sonst ja du hast ja aber
nimmer gemeldet und hobby natürlich
meint was ist das mein carrerabahn
martha wir sind seit einem halben jahr
getrennt und jetzt möchte ich dich
bitten
du musst mich gar nicht lange bitten ich
sitze ja schon rote rosen was gibt es zu
essen
das essen ist nicht für dich los komm
mit komik schwäche muss klar sein dass
geht mir jetzt ein bisschen zu schnell
[Gelächter]
der preis für die sich der räuber nicht
vorstellen freut sich der herr passende
der papa schau dich ruhig um sich ein
neues zuhause
gott der schwund sexy poster was ist
[Applaus]
dass der böse blick hat die blicke mein
leben versaut der böse mann und jetzt
glaubte das ist mit einem essen wieder
gutmachen kann wirklich klar
was hätte das gerät werden soll
[Musik]
johannes muss willst du jetzt doch die
broncos mützen schulter wird darüber ist
sich der feine adrenalin und
gästeservice aber jetzt machen wir es so
jetzt kannst du vielleicht mit der marke
schon vor die zum schutz bedrohter
häufiger oder zähne und wenn dann hat
meine freundin kommt gebe meine freundin
kommt dann essen wir dann schneiders und
dann komme sofort nach eine freundin
also ich habe meine freundin gehört ja
meine freundin und das mir ist jetzt
eigentlich sei was sonst manche alle
leute heute da die ich kenne und dann
noch versucht sich jetzt aber bis und
plötzlich tag herr pusch
ich möchte mit ihnen über gott sprechen
warum so besteht die grünen haben
du hast dein glück das mir als besucher
dabei in fünf minuten war es dem
schmorbraten ein verbreiteter die
vorschlags hitzfeld vorstellig extrem ja
was er es nicht dass sie die neue
normalerweise suchen männer sich doch
eine jüngere
für mich hat er sich nie so viel mühe
gegeben egal in diesem bereich brauchen
wir nur noch wenig passende musik
geklappt
[Musik]
ich fühle mich ein bisschen wie beim
captain's dinner aufgewertet wer mag das
wohl sein
[Musik]
dass ich den sport beraten würde ich
ungern kalt werden lassen sie los
schön dass du da bist ich wollte
unbedingt mit dir über gott sprechen
weil ich von morgen nämlich nach island
und wollte ich dich fragen ob du nicht
meine frau gießen könnte weil der
rosarote staubsauger der kerker mit mir
man muss die feste feiern wie sie fallen
[Applaus]
[Musik]